so we've got desantis he's out there
with the alligators hunting down the gay
people then you've got the mayor of new
york city and despite the murder and the
rape and the crime and all that stuff
and the high house prices and the
disastrous economy he's saying gays come
here we'll take you guys we'll save you
from scary alligator man ron desantis uh
then we showed you how the white house
lies and obfuscates the truth related to
all that but at least i was going dave
you got to find me a silver lining here
thank god we have cnn right because
these people wouldn't lie to us they
wouldn't frame the issue completely
dishonestly and confuse things and
conflate things and push an agenda
that's not what they would do on cnn
there is an ugly history in the united
states of portraying gays lesbians
transgender people
as perverts as predators who are preying
on children
and when i see some of the coverage in
the last week
seems to me they are just repeating an
ugly history
good morning brian yeah it's it's
exasperating to watch all this go down i
can't believe that it's 2022
and we're still seeing lgbtq families be
framed as predatory or as uh diversive
or
i would say as uh almost almost
perverted i mean that seems to be the
message to millions of lgbtq families by
the actions of governor desantis right
now and i
it's heartbreaking to watch because
these are families who already struggle
to get by day to day in the public
square and now have their own government
going after them just for existing when
i'm watching the fox coverage this week
i'm thinking they know what they're
doing like this is something that's very
compelling and scary to their audience
well brian you're right it's it's
brilliant framing because you can't
argue with a parent's right to influence
their child parents care deeply about
their children i'm a parent i get it and
when you focus on this particular subset
kindergarten through third grade again
it's very smart and it's strategic
because most parents will say well yeah
i guess that makes sense it seems pretty
common sense that we wouldn't be talking
about sex or sexual orientation but it
it sort of hides the uh the real
intention behind the bill and the thing
about parental rights framing is that
this is not the first time we've seen
this in american history if you frame uh
you know critical race theory against
parental rights then people feel okay we
have a right to be upset if you think
about go back to segregation
there was a parental rights argument
about we shouldn't really be integrating
and having our kids you know in schools
based on race because that will
introduce another level of intimacy or
relationship and so when you go at that
personal angle you will actually get a
lot of people who miss the sort of
bigger picture behind
what what this bill is really about and
it has a chilling effect
okay so the reason i wanted to show you
that is because that woman almost got it
right she almost got it right
that this stuff makes sense it makes
sense you would not want your kids to be
taught gender theory when they're first
graders and then have that hidden from
the parents it makes sense you would not
want them being taught critical race
theory in school and then have that
hidden from the parents then she tries
to link it somehow to slavery and racism
and all of those other things it's
nonsense it's nonsense they want your
kids i'm not even saying it's because
they're grooming them because they're
pedophiles or whatever the hell everyone
else is saying i'm just saying they just
want to break children and they want to
break the family i think that's pretty
obvious and let's not forget the black
lives matter website when this whole
thing all started all this crazy woke
nonsense started over the last couple
years used to have a section
in it talking about destroying the
nuclear family these things are all
connected so they almost kind of got it
right on cnn but then at the end she but
you know parents really shouldn't have
to do something with that because it's
really kind of hide in bigotry or
something well i want to show you the
two the two chirons that they had here
uh now this first one here focus on
parental rights chips away at gay rights
so let's just pretend you're the average
cnn viewer and you're obviously not that
bright you don't really know what's
going on and you just regurgitate
talking points and all of that one more
time throw it up you would see that
you'd flip on cnn right and no one's
really paying attention to cnn but you
flip it on and you go my god parental
rights are chipping away at gay rights
now that has nothing to do
with this bill there is no one coming
for gay rights in florida do you think
that if ron desantis
and the other right-wing maniacs of
florida were saying we're going to jail
gays we are not going to let gay people
get married we are not going to let gay
people have certain jobs we are not
going to let gay people have kids we're
not going to let gay people buy property
anything that would actually make gay
people unequal under the law you think i
might say something about it i assure
you that i would i assure you that i
would this is about indoctrinating
children
from state employees and then hiding
that from the parents so that that
chiron is an absolute lie and by the way
throw it up one more time you see how
they're contrasting these things so that
they're they're trying to train you
to think that parental rights are bad or
that parental rights are in conflict
with gay rights which is insane gay
rights
used to just be about equality the gays
of stonewall
i know this is i can't wait till the
media matters hit piece on this one the
gays of stonewall would be horrified by
what's going on right now they were
fighting for equality they were fighting
to be equal under the law they were not
fighting for all of this other nonsense
that really is the truth okay it really
is those people who were being arrested
because they were going to bars and as
consenting adults meeting other people
and trying to be in equal relationships
that's what it was about it had nothing
to do with any of this so the media is
now trying they're trying to show you
that parental rights are scary and in
conflict with the thing that you better
worship the most which are gay rights
and by the way we have gay rights it's
equal we're good let's go to the other
chiron for a second the lgbt community
latest to be caught in the culture work
now first off look at these two people i
just want to be clear i have nothing to
do with either one of these dudes and i
mean that as a
as a newscaster or whatever i am or as a
supposed member of the lgbt community um
but the lgbt community latest to be
caught in culture war
they brought the culture war to us
the gay thing was basically over
and this is why you twisted mother
the gay thing was over donald trump in
2016 was on stage before
becoming president with a rainbow flag
saying he did not care who you marry
saying that he didn't care about trans
bathrooms because he's a builder and if
he was building a hotel and you told him
he only had to build one bathroom he
would be thrilled because it would save
him money peter thiel
an openly gay man spoke at the rnc
convention where they nominated donald
trump and said he is a proud gay man and
got a standing ovation
standing ovation i've discussed that
with him privately many times he was
shocked he did not know what was going
to happen when that happened and he got
a standing ovation okay
this thing was done it doesn't mean that
every conservative has to agree with gay
marriage and it doesn't mean that we
have to trample on your religious
liberty and all of those things but this
[ __ ] was over and these people are
dragging it back in because this has
nothing to do with equality anymore